[Music]
making a musical it's so special and
it's so thrilling because for one brief
moment you're watching hundreds of
people all speak the same language at
the same time
[Music]
this is 155 for 157 we want to make sure
it's sort of forte piano and NASA
crescendo okay
[Music]
the musical brief for spirited was to
create a score that becomes a Christmas
classic so much of our process is
strategizing how does this song deliver
what we need to deliver for each moment
am I forever
unredeemable
when you're working on a script you kind
of it's like a flashlight where you can
only see a little bit in front of you
and then you have to have faith that you
can keep going and like things reveal
themselves to you the more that you sort
of shine that light and eventually you
get to where you're going
[Music]
sometimes you find an incredible moment
of emotion for a character or an idea
that could become musicalized that just
leaps out of the dialogue and becomes a
song
[Music]
favorable
the great thing about this story is it
goes to so many different places because
the material and the plot allowed us to
just go there each time oh it would be
[Music]
it has everything from a epic Bernard
Hermann film score
to contemporary pop gospel that's the
view from here to a big London British
Musical
[Music]
it was so fun to contain all these
different facets and then mesh them
together
we had a ton of opportunities to bring
in dancers and big choirs and which is
just a thrill to get to record them and
have that sound
[Music]
the score has been mind-blowing I've
never heard anything like this in my
entire life
it's a very special experience I don't
know that we'll ever get this kind of
chance or this kind of experience again
so we're trying to soak up every single
minute of it
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]